바다는 인류에게 가장 오래된 길이었습니다.
자동차가 생기기 전에도, 비행기가 생기기 전에도
사람과 물건은 배를 타고 움직였습니다.
그런데 이상하게도 가장 오래된 이 교통수단은
가장 늦게 바뀌고 있습니다.
도로 위에서는 이미 전기차가 낯설지 않습니다.
테슬라, 아이오닉, EV6, BYD 전기차까지
이제 전기차는 미래 기술이라기보다
현실의 산업이 됐습니다.
그렇다면 자연스럽게 이런 질문이 생깁니다.
자동차가 전기로 바뀌었다면
배도 전기로 바뀔 수 있지 않을까?
최근 흐름만 보면 가능성은 분명히 보입니다.
전기페리 주문이 늘고 있고,
전기호트가 바다를 건너고 있고,
중국에서는 1만 톤급 순수 전기 컨테이너선까지
운항을 시작했습니다.
배터리 기업들도 선박용 배터리와
항만 충전 시스템을 새로운 시장으로 보고 있죠.
그러니까 전기 선박 시장이 커지고 있다는 말은 과장이 아닙니다.
분명히 시장은 움직이고 있습니다.
하지만 전기 선박 시장이 커지는 것과
전기차처럼 모든 배가 전기로 바뀌는 것은
같은 이야기일까요?
오늘 우리가 주목할 이야기는 바로 이 지점입니다.
배는 자동차보다 훨씬 더 까다로운 물리법칙 위에 놓여있고,
그래서 되는 배와 안 되는 배가 아주 분명하게 갈립니다.
먼저 전기차를 생각해보죠.
전기차의 핵심 문제는 배터리 가격, 충전 속도, 주행거리였습니다.
하지만 시간이 지나면서 배터리 가격은 내려갔고,
충전소는 늘어났고, 주행거리도 길어졌습니다.
그래서 사람들은 배도 비슷하지 않을까 생각합니다.
배터리가 좋아지고,
충전시설만 깔리면 결국 배도 전기로 바뀌지 않겠냐는 겁니다.
그런데 배는 자동차와 전혀 다릅니다.
자동차는 도로 위를 달립니다.
중간에 충전소가 있고, 문제가 생기면 갓길에 세울 수 있습니다.
하지만 배는 바다 위를 갑니다.
바다 한가운데에는 충전소가 없습니다.
한 번 항구를 떠나면 그 배 안에 실은 에너지로 목적지까지 가야 합니다.
여기서부터 전기 선박의 첫 번째 벽이 생깁니다.
바로 항속거리입니다.
작은 보트나 페리는 정해진 거리입니다.
배터리만 오가면 됩니다.
하지만 컨테이너선이나 유조선은 며칠, 몇 주씩 바다를 건너야 합니다.
이 거리를 배터리만으로 감당하려면 엄청난 양의 배터리를 실어야겠죠.
문제는 배터리를 많이 실을수록 배가 무거워진다는 겁니다.
배가 무거워지면 더 많은 에너지가 필요하고,
그러면 다시 배터리를 더 실어야 합니다.
이것이 전기 선박의 딜레마입니다.
전기차도 배터리 무게 문제가 있지만,
배에서는 이 문제가 훨씬 더 크게 작동합니다.
배는
화물을 실어 돈을 버는 운송수단이기 때문입니다.
컨테이너선은 컨테이너를 실어야 합니다.
유조선은 원유를 실어야 합니다.
벌크선은 철광석과 곡물을 실어야 합니다.
그런데 배터리가 그 공간을 차지하기 시작하면,
문제는 기술이 아니라 사업성이 됩니다.
전기차는 배터리를 싣고 사람을 옮기지만,
컨테이너선은 화물을 실어서 돈을 법니다.
두 번째 배구는 물입니다.
배는 톤당 거리당으로 보면 트럭이나 비행기보다 훨씬 효율적인 운송수단입니다.
전세계 무역이 배에 의존하는 이유도 여기에 있습니다.
그런데 이것이 곧 전기화가 쉽다는 뜻은 아닙니다.
자동차는 공기를 가르며 달리지만 배는 물을 밀고 갑니다.
물은 공기보다 훨씬 밀도가 높죠.
수영장에서 빨리 움직이려 할 때 몸이 무거워지는 것처럼,
배도 속도를 올릴수록 에너지 소모가 급격하게 커집니다.
게다가 배는 빠르게 갈수록 자기 앞에 파도를 만듭니다.
어느 순간부터는 그냥 앞으로 가는 것이 아니라 자신이 만든 파도를
계속 타고 넘어가야 합니다.
쉽게 말하면 배가 스스로 언덕을 만들고 그 언덕을 계속 올라가는 셈입니다.
세 번째 배구는 충전입니다.
대형 전기 선박을 충전하려면 항구에 메가와트급 전력 인프라가 필요합니다.
단순히 콘센트를 꽂는 문제가 아닙니다.
항만의 전력망, 변전설비, 충전장비, 안전규정, 운영시스템까지 함께 바뀌어야 합니다.
배는 항구에 오래 머무르지 않는 경우도 많습니다.
빨리 싣고 빨리 내리고 다시 출항해야 하기 때문입니다.
결국 선박만 바뀐다고 되는 것이 아니라 항구가 같이 바뀌어야 하는 겁니다.
네 번째 배구는 안전입니다.
전기차 배터리도 화재 위험이 있지만 선박용 배터리는 훨씬 더 복잡할 겁니다.
바다 위에는 염분, 습기, 진동, 온도 변화가 있고 화재가 났을 때 쉽게 대응하기도 어렵습니다.
그래서 선박용 배터리실은 단순한 배터리 창고가 아닐 겁니다.
냉각, 환기, 방수, 방화, 승무원 훈련까지 포함된 하나의 거대한 공학 시스템을 만들어야겠죠.
그래서 전기 선박은 배터리만 달면 끝이 아닙니다.
결국 전기 선박이 어려운 이유는 사업성이 없기 때문이죠.
돈이 안 된다는 겁니다.
물론 짧은 연한 항로나 강을 따라 움직이는 컨테이너선은 다를 겁니다.
정해진 구간을 오가는 방식이라면 배터리 용량과 충전 계획을 노선에 맞춰서 설계할 수 있겠죠.
하지만 이것을 보고 컨테이너선도 곧 전기로 바뀌겠구나라고 생각하면 안 됩니다.
짧은 항로에 전기 컨테이너선은 가능성이 있지만
태평양과 대서양으로 오가는
초대형 컨테이너선이 배터리만으로 움직이는 그림은 아주 먼 이야기입니다.
그러니까 전기 선박의 미래를 볼 때 가장 피해야 할 생각은 모든 배가 결국 전기로 간다는 생각이겠죠.
그래서 전기 선박의 미래는 모든 배의 전기화가 아니라 전기가 잘 맞는 배부터 빠르게 바뀌는 쪽에 가깝습니다.
가장 먼저 현실이 될 곳은 페리입니다.
페리는 노선이 정해져 있고 거리가 비교적 짧고 출발지와 도착지가 반복됩니다.
승객과 차량을 태우고 내리는 동안
항구에 머무는 시간도 있습니다.
그 시간이 곧 충전 시간이 될 수 있겠죠.
또 페리는 도심이나 관광지 가까이에서 움직이는 경우가 많습니다.
매연과 소음이 먼 바닷가가 아니라 사람들이 사는 항구도시 한복판에서 발생한다는 겁니다.
그래서 페리의 전기화는 단순한 친환경 정책이 아닙니다.
도시의 공기, 소음, 시민 건강과 바로 연결된 문제입니다.
초기 비용은 높을 수 있습니다.
하지만 전기는 연료비가 낮고 전기모토는 디젤 엔진모토입니다.
페리와 노선의 구조가 단순합니다.
매일 같은 노선을 반복하는 페리라면 연료비와 정비비 절감 효과도 비교적 빨리 드러날 수 있습니다.
그래서 전기 선박의 첫 번째 대중시장은 거대한 컨테이너선이 아니라 짧은 항로를 오가는 페리일 가능성이 큽니다.
요트와 관광선도 가능성이 있겠죠.
페리가 경제성과 반복 운항의 문제라면 요트와 관광선은 경험과 사치의 문제입니다.
요트에서 사람들은 쉬고 자고 바다를 봅니다.
그런데 옆에서 디젤 엔진이 나뉘어 있습니다.
고급 요트는 전기와 소음이 진동하고 냄새와 소음을 만든다면 그 경험이 크게 떨어지겠죠.
반면에 전기 요트는 조용하고 진동이 적고 냄새도 적습니다.
물론 전기 요트가 곧바로 대중시장이 된다는 뜻은 아니지만 고급 요트 시장은 가격보다 경험의 차이를 크게 보는 시장입니다.
그래서 이런 프리미엄 시장에서 전기화가 먼저 일어날 수 있습니다.
결국 중요한 건 베이크 기간입니다.
얼마나 멀리 가느냐, 얼마나 빨리 가느냐, 어디서 충전할 수 있느냐,
운항 패턴이 얼마나 예측 가능하느냐,
이 조건이 맞는 배부터 전기화가 시작되는 겁니다.
세계적인 흐름도 한 방향으로만 움직이지 않습니다.
환경 규제가 강하고 짧은 수상 노선이 많은 시장에서는 전기 페리가 먼저 커지고 있습니다.
고급 레저 문화가 있는 시장에서는 전기 요트와 전기 스포츠 보트가 먼저 등장하고 있습니다.
배터리와 조선 제조력이 강한 시장에서는 전기 관광선, 연합 물류선, 전기 컨테이너선 같은 상업용 모델이 실험되고 있습니다.
결론은 분명합니다.
전기 선박 시장은 커지고 있습니다.
하지만 전기차처럼 모든 선박이 한꺼번에 전기로 바뀌는 그림은 아닐 겁니다.
매일 같은 항로를 오가는 페리, 항구 주변의 수상 교통, 활동반경이 정해진 소형 보트에서 먼저 전기화가 일어날 가능성이 큽니다.
전기 선박에 관한 질문은 배도 전기차처럼 될 수 있을까가 아닙니다.
진짜 질문은 어떤 배가 전기에 맞는가입니다.
전기 선박은 모든 바다를 한 번에 바꾸지는 못할 겁니다.
하지만 항구와 도시, 관광지와 짧은 항구,
항로부터 조용히 바꾸기 시작할 겁니다.
전기 선박의 시대는 오고 있습니다.
다만 그것은 전기차에서 봤던 방식과는 전혀 다른 속도, 다른 순서, 다른 시장에서 시작되고 있습니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.